i do need your advice on something which
is uh we moved into
a theater a very nice a prominent comedy
theater
here in los angeles called largo and uh
we're doing shows out of there now
i know that you've had legitimate
theater experience
maybe you could give me some tips uh you
performed in the west end in london i
think didn't you
i did it's a the i performed at the
royal haymarket
in the west end which is sort of the
biggest
most traditional oldest theater in the
west end you know there they have
because it's in
the uk they have a royal box
for the queen if she gains to come to
see the entertainment
i don't know what the like would be at
largo
if if they have the uk royal ball i
don't know what it would be who would
the box before at largo in los angeles
it would probably be or the director of
the department of water
you know um yes that would that would be
the
that's the equivalent of royalty in la
is who get who can get you
extra water for your lawn it would be
something i thought it might be like uh
a kardashian box
well if now you're you're talking about
true royalty now
yes well yeah exactly so the royal boxes
you know obviously the queen is not
really
into theater so it's empty all the time
but i was doing a few good
men uh with aaron sorkin
and one day the box was
had people in it and i and i noticed i
was doing the you can't handle the truth
scene the big fireworks scene at the end
and i looked over and they were
having sex there's a couple
in the royal box having sex 100 having
sex with
total abandon by the way and
what when i i was like couldn't believe
it and apparently that it was a thing
like if you do enough
theater in the in the uh in the west end
this couple is notorious like it's their
thing oh that's what they
do that's what they do yeah it is it
is their thing how they get into the
royal box i don't know but um
so i'm just saying cafe largo it's a
live theater conan
you you need to be ready for anything
that could happen and literally anything
i'm basically here with about four
socially distanced male crew members
wearing masks are any of them having sex
three of them yeah well there you go